d'abord un point sur la situation au
tchad il ya des manifestations qui sont
réprimées
on parle de 7 voire neuf morts selon une
ong
est ce que cette situation elle est en
train de dégénérer je pense que la
situation est à dire n'est pas
totalement en train de dégénérer mais il
était question c'est à dire de définir
de la ligne politique du conseil
militaire de transition qui a été mis en
place et notamment le rôle qui pourrait
être celui de la france comme vous ne
savez au premier quart de cette
situation la france a immédiatement
apporté son soutien au conseil militaire
de transition beaucoup de nombreux
tchadiens notamment l'opinion publique
et même les politiques cela et a été
appréhendé comme étant un soutien
apporté à une succession dynastique au
sommet de l'état voilà pourquoi il était
de bon ton pour le président macro
lorsqu'il a pris la parole aujourd'hui
des dicos fait la france avait apporté
ce soutien compte tenu de l'urgence des
situations à savoir la rébellion qui
arrivait djamena et qu'il n'est en aucun
cas question de soutenir une quelconque
succession dynastique à la tête de
l'état la france soutient donc le
processus démocratique et je pense que
c'est pardon suffiront à apaiser c'est à
dire les esprits mais ce que nous dit
c'est que la france à quelques pains
directement une part de responsabilité
sur les manifestations que l'on observe
aujourd'hui
au tchad la manifestation elle est le
fait des leaders politiques notamment
monsieur succès marmara qui a réussi à
mettre des jeunes est dans la rue c'est
parce que comme je le souligne un y
avait comme une action
le président deby est décédé et à la
tête du conseil militaire des
transitions se trouvera son fils mamad
débit pour certaines personnes et
notamment lors des funérailles
on a vu des faire coter en djamena
dirigeants et notamment le président
marc rond qui sont venus comme pour
adouber la transition qui avait été mise
en place
voilà pourquoi ce temps on qualifier
cela de coûts des cas et je pense que ce
sont ces manifestations que l'on
pourrait dans la rue ou dénoncer une
situation samedi qui violerait l'ordre
constitutionnel et à partir du moment où
la france pendant la parole pour dire
que tel n'est pas le cas et qu'elle
soutenait sardines ou dénouer membres
d'une transition démocratique
je pense que cela suffira à apaiser
alors justement c'est ce qu'il a tenté
de faire de désamorcer un peu la
situation humaine elle macron la
position française vis-à-vis de ce
conseil militaire de transition au tchad
puisqu'il a dit je ne suis pas pour un
plan de succession l'a entendu tout à
l'heure vous pensez que ce sera
suffisant pour apaiser la situation là
bas
l'opposition et la société civile je
pense que cela n'est pas tout à fait
suffisant mais il faut comprendre la
situation dans laquelle le pays est
plongé aujourd'hui je ne pense pas que
les rebelles en enlevant la vie à au
président déby à dire il devait
s'arrêter en si bon chemin
leur objectif est de prendre n'djamena
donc il faut donc mettre sur pied un
mécanisme ce à dire qu'ils puissent ne
serait ce que pour cette situation
d'urgence
encadrer nos pays ça dit la souveraineté
du pays
voilà pourquoi la france dans un premier
temps fait dire comme le président marc
on l'a si bien souligné il était
question ça dure et d'apporter tout le
soutien
c'est et institutions soutien politique
mais aussi soutien militaire parce qu'au
moment où nous parlons il convient de
souligner que les positions rebelles ont
été bombardés grâce au soutien français
je pense donc que la transition qui a
été remise en place fire pour 18 mois
elle est appelée à organiser un dialogue
inclusif qui réunira tous les tous les
tchadiens et à l'issue de ces dialogues
on a on ira au fait que dans tous les
cas vers des élections dites vous croyez
que le fisc et d'idriss deby itno défunt
président il doit s'exprimer d'ailleurs
c'est ce qu'il a annoncé matin idriss
deby vous croyez qu'il va qu'il peut
assurer lui cette transition est
transféré le pouvoir aux civils
dans tous les cas fait que le conseil
militaire de transition s'est engagé
pour 18 mois et convient de souligner
que dans ses 18 de noir c'est à dire il
ya derrière la communauté internationale
notamment l'union africaine par la voix
de son président félix si ce que dit qui
a demandé à ce que les voies
démocratiques soient observés c'est à
dire en matière de transition
mais il ya aussi le nord de la france
qui jusqu'à la peau de nombreux
observateurs étaient assez flou
maintenant que la france actuellement
estimé sa position c'est à dire vers des
élections qui seraient démocratique
je pense que les militaires au pouvoir
en djamena n'ont pas suffisamment de
moyens c'est à dire pour contrôler le
pouvoir ou des landais cette période
plastique convient de le souligner si la
rébellion n'est pas arrivé en terminale
c'est grâce à une opération française
qui a dû bombardé certaines de nos
positions pour qu'ils ne parviennent pas
à 9
alors justement vous avez précisé pas de
parler de flics qui s'était dit le
président de la république démocratique
du congo qui est à paris aujourd'hui qui
a rencontré macron se sont exprimés sur
le tchad
il dirige aujourd'hui
la présidence tournante de l'union
africaine est ce qu'il est ce que la rdc
va jouer un rôle justement pour
permettre au tchad de se stabiliser et
de repousser
justement les positions rebelles je
pense que vous faites la rdc en tant que
pays souverain c'est à dire n'a pas
forcément je dirais les moyens qui
seraient militaires voire fait et
diplomatique pour apporter un quelconque
soutien route yade la rdc sijsling par
la voix de son président qui en même
temps président de l'union africaine il
s'agit donc c'est à dire d'envoyer la
communauté internationale vers les
principes qui régissent l'union
africaine à savoir le respect des
principes démocratiques les transitions
de pouvoir a dit qu'ils doivent se faire
par des élections libres
mais la ldc également par la voix de son
président c'est à dire va s'appuyer sur
des mécanismes internationaux notamment
les nations unies mais aussi l'union
européenne ce n'est pas gênant ce hasard
de calendrier
si on peut dire des choses ainsi la
présence des présidents congolais à à
paris aujourd'hui je ne pense pas à fait
que ce soit un hasard de calendrier
nos présidents congolais et le président
marc l'on s'était déjà vu la semaine
dernière aux funérailles du président
deby mais le président qui ce que dit
devait également passés en france parce
que il faut quand même le souligner en
tant que président en exercice de
l'union africaine
il est au coeur de plusieurs événements
qui réuniront la france et l'afrique
dans les prochains jours je voulais dire
ce que je voulais sous-entendre en fait
c'est que c'est on entend peu les
institutions panafricaines sur la
situation au tchad en afrique centrale
est beaucoup plus la voix de la france
mais comme on l'a toujours souligné
c'est à dire
l'union africaine a en elle même sa
poupée que ce soit l'union l'africain
sud au plan global où les institutions
sous régionales
ce sont c'est à dire des généraux sans
troupe parce que derrière il faut une
certaine contrainte et vous comprenez
que c'est à dire la voix de la france
pèse significativement parce que je suis
le plan militaire la france est présente
elle est déjà présente à dire en djamena
à travers de l'opération épervier qui
date des années 1990 mais il faut
également souligner que l'opération d'un
canapé au quartier général djamena et à
côté de ça c'est à dire vous avez
presque 500 hommes stationnés à dire en
charge et de contourner la situation
dans l'ombre en salle qu'il n'ait pas
joué dans ce plan n'est pas beaucoup vu
l'immensité de la région du sel
c'est un défi pour la france aussi de
d'être impliqué dans les événements
chaoui en plus du mali et oui oui partie
de la mauritanie jusqu'au soudan c'est à
peu près 3 millions de kilomètres carrés
mais il faut quand même le souvenir que
fait la france est déjà présente en
train de mobiliser ses partenaires pour
pouvoir apporter un début de solution à
différents défis sécurité qui se posent
et je pense que c'est ce poids
significatif qui a d'ailleurs permis
comme je le soulignais dante aux
rebelles de ne pas arriver en djamena
voilà pourquoi de façon tellement
dramatiques cead il est question de
s'appuyer en france que de s'appuyer sur
les instances sous régionale qui peuvent
condamner mais n'ont pas de moyens de
contrainte pour pouvoir obtenir la
situation sur le terrain et pour
terminer très rapidement à votre avis
l'issue de de cette situation ces
tensions au tchad la situation en fait
en elle-même et convient de souligner
que le conseil militaire de transition
il est vraiment entre le marteau et
l'enclume parce que il ya là une triple
je dirais
pression qui s'abat sur nos conseils
c'est à dire il ya des gens c'est ça dit
cette expression de la rébellion qui n'a
pas désarmé qui a fait un repli
stratégique dans des pays tels que le
niger et qui deviendra c'est à dire
lorsque la situation se sera calmée il y
a aussi parlé d'agression ils tiennent à
savoir l'opposition démocratique qui
voudraient sa dirait une transition
qu'il déposait sur les principes
vraiment démocratique mais aussi il y à
la pression internationale les nations
unies mais dossier la france qui est
d'avancer de cette transition
aujourd'hui et je pense qu au delà de
toutes ces tensions
nos délais de 18 du mois c'est à dire
sera sous peu les observer et il n'est
pas question ici c'est pas donné de
vivre une transition saadé qui va
s'éterniser
merci beaucoup à vous les hong kong où
je rappelle que vous êtes politologue
spécialiste en relations internationales